[Música]
rusia indicó que mil setecientos treinta
militares ucranianos se han rendido esta
semana en la acería a su hostal último
bastión de resistencia del puerto de
mariupol en el sureste de ucrania es
incierto el número de personas que aún
continúan en la siderúrgica ucrania e
insiste en que busca un intercambio de
los militares que dicen fueron evacuados
antes de partir hacia en su primer viaje
como presidente eeuu yo bailé recibió a
los líderes de suecia y de finlandia
tras sus solicitudes de ingreso a la
otan
bardem se mostró confiado en que
lograrán la membresía pese al veto de
turquía en la alianza militar
a la espera de que la primera ministra
de francia elizabeth point renueve el
gabinete de cara a los comicios
parlamentarios de junio la líder realizó
su primera actividad oficial y les
contamos los aspectos a tener en cuenta
para el nuevo gobierno
bienvenidos son además de las noticias
de france mit y 4 en español gracias por
acompañarnos como todos los días y
santiago ariztía y comenzamos este
informativo con información sobre la
guerra en ucrania rusia afirmó que más
de mil 700 combatientes ucranianos se
rindieron esta semana en mariupol
ucrania por su parte que dice que tiene
como objetivo asegurar un intercambio de
prisioneros no ha informado cuántos
combatientes permanecían dentro de la
planta siderúrgica el comité
internacional de la cruz roja por su
parte asegura que avanza en un registro
de quienes salieron de la planta de azov
tal para informar sobre su situación y
garantizar además el contacto con sus
familiares mientras tanto desde el
ministerio de defensa ruso dieron más
precisiones escuchemos
las fuerzas armadas rusas continúan su
operación especial en ucrania durante
las últimas 24 horas
771 militantes del regimiento
nacionalistas op se rindieron en la
acería a sus tal bloqueada en mariupol
un total de 1.730 militantes se han
rendido desde el 16 de mayo incluidos 80
heridos todos los que necesitan tratar
hospitalario están siendo tratados en
las instalaciones médicas de la
república popular de la unesco en
novasoft y dónetsk y hace ya meses
cuando transcurría el cuarto día de
invasión de rusia a ucrania oleksandr y
el y por un hombre de 62 años recibió un
disparo en la cabeza mientras se
encontraba desarmado en una localidad
del este ucraniano ahora el soldado ruso
que lo asesinó se enfrenta a un juicio
por posibles crímenes de guerra y en la
segunda jornada de audiencias pidió
perdón este es el primer proceso de esta
índole desde que comenzó la invasión
rodrigo sedano con los lines fort con
los detalles
por favor dime te arrepentiste el crimen
que cometiste
si admito mi culpabilidad entiendo que
no podrás perdonarme pero te pido perdón
es el segundo día de un juicio de gran
importancia simbólica para ucrania el
primero por crímenes de guerra desde la
invasión rusa el acusado badín si si
marín pidió perdón a la viuda de
oleksandr se lee pop de 62 años en el
cuarto día de la invasión rusa así si
marín le disparó en la cabeza pese a ser
un civil desarmado
y a
tenía un disparo en la cabeza corría
hacia él y se veía su cerebro bueno el
cráneo estaba perforado
el hecho ocurrió en la localidad de
chupan kit acá en el noreste ucraniano
algo que el acusado admitió durante el
primer día del juicio según sisi marín
vieron al hombre hablar por teléfono y
un oficial le obligó a disparar porque
podría dar la alerta al ejército
ucraniano él ordenó disparar yo no
disparé y entonces otro oficial que
estaba al lado del conductor se dio la
vuelta y comenzó a ordenar me en tono
amenazante que disparará o que de lo
contrario no alcanzaríamos a nuestras
tropas y no podríamos pedir refuerzos y
que estábamos en peligro con tan sólo 21
años y si marín era sargento y
comandante de un tanque ahora tras
admitir su culpabilidad podría
enfrentarse a cadena perpetua el soldado
dice aceptar la pena la viuda así lo
pide si bien afirma que aceptaría un
intercambio por prisioneros de atos tal
y en otras noticias el presidente eeuu
yo bailé han recibido en la casa blanca
a los líderes de suecia y de finlandia
esto por supuesto tras sus solicitudes
de ingreso
bardem se reunió con la primera ministra
sueca magdalena anderson y con el
presidente finlandés sound link ministro
para discutir sus solicitudes que
implican a abandonar años de neutralidad
la adhesión a la otan está sujeta a la
aprobación de todos los estados miembros
y turquía ha manifestado ya sus reparos
y también sus condiciones en esta línea
ankara pediría a suecia que deje de
apoyar a los militantes kurdos
considerados por turquía como grupos
terroristas y que ambos países también
levanten sus provisiones sobre algunas
ventas de armas a turquía el mandatario
finlandés dijo que su país está
dispuesto a discutir las preocupaciones
de ankara mientras que el presidente de
job aiden aseguró que su administración
presentaría este mismo jueves al
congreso informes sobre la adhesión de
ambas naciones
y hoy me enorgullece asegurarles que
cuentan con el respaldo total total y
completo de los eeuu de américa hoy mi
administración está presentando el
congreso de eeuu informes sobre la
atención al otan de ambos países para
que el senado pueda pasar rápidamente
asesorar y consentir el tratado
como aliados de la otan nos
comprometeremos con la seguridad de
turquía al igual que turquía se
comprometerá con nuestra seguridad nos
formamos el terrorismo en serio estamos
abiertos a discutir todas las
preocupaciones que turquía pueda tener
con respecto a nuestra membresía de una
manera abierta y constructiva
cambiamos de tema de vamos a francia
donde la nueva primera ministra hablamos
de elisabeth bone realizó su primera
actividad oficial en las afueras de
parís concentrada en las mujeres y en
las niñas mientras se espera la pronta
escogencia de su nuevo gobierno de
talles con nuestra periodista en la
capital francesa y ha sido una actividad
dedicada a la igualdad de las mujeres ya
la emancipación de la mujer elisabeth
bond se encuentra el lema hugo esto es
en la periferia del país y en esa comuna
está reuniéndose con organizaciones que
trabajan justamente por la igualdad
hombre-mujer hace algunos ratos estaba
hablando con un montón de jovencitas que
se han comprometido en el consejo
municipal de los niños por decirlo y
ellas les hacían preguntas muy directas
no sobre qué piensa ella cómo entró por
ejemplo al mundo empresarial qué piensa
de la igualdad hombre-mujer y también de
una cosa que se usa mucho aquí en
francia que es el mentor ado o tutores
que son personas que ayudan sobre todo a
jóvenes que quieren realizar estudios y
que por ejemplo tienen una situación
familiar complicada o una situación
económica complicada bueno ahí se ha
visto a ella que siempre hemos dicho es
una mujer es muy técnica muy seria un
poco más
desenvuelta que de costumbre mientras
ella tiene esta actividad que tiene que
ver justamente con el discurso que dio
cuando asumió como primera ministra
recordemos que lanzó al final un mensaje
a las niñas para que no dejen de
perseguir sus sueños y que la lucha por
la igualdad de la mujer en la sociedad
nunca se detenga se le vio un poco más
desenvuelta y esta actividad le permite
evadirse un poco de la gran duda que
planea sobre este gobierno en principio
ayer había una reunión de gabinete fue
propuesta porque todavía no hay los
nombres de todos los ministros y se ha
puesto una nueva fecha para mañana
veremos si al final lo consiguen se dice
que el presidente manuel macrón aunque
ella es la que propone los nombres es
finalmente el presidente quien decide si
sí o sí no busca sobre todo a candidatos
a ministros que sean más bien políticos
justamente porque ellas una tecnócrata y
también que no sean candidato para las
legislativas para que no haya luego un
cambio de gabinete muy pronto después de
las elecciones legislativas y obviamente
de la función de este gabinete y
precisamente con elisabeth bond el
presidente manuel macro no trata de
remodelar su gabinete de cara a los
comicios parlamentarios de junio y para
formar una nueva administración deben
tomar en cuenta varios diferentes
elementos a continuación les explicamos
algunos de ellos
cuando se forma un nuevo gobierno en
francia el presidente y el primer
ministro deben respetar una serie de
principios el primero de ellos es
incorporar a pesos pesados a pesar de
las diferencias políticas en 2012 por
ejemplo el presidente reelegido jacques
chirac nombró a nicolas sarkozy como
ministro del interior con quien mantenía
unas frías relaciones desde 1995 lo
mismo pasó en 2014 cuando ségolène royal
se convirtió en ministra de medio
ambiente bajo el mandato del entonces
presidente françois hollande su antiguo
esposo y en 2017 cuando bruno le maire
crítico acérrimo de manuel macro se
convirtió en su ministro de economía
hemos acordado dejar de lado nuestras
inútiles rencillas políticas para evitar
las discusiones por diferencias que no
existen que no exista para el segundo
principio a seguir es formar un gobierno
equilibrado paridad de género pero
también asegurarse de que el gabinete
incluya representantes de todos los
territorios el último criterio un
elemento de sorpresa por parte del jefe
de estado el ejemplo más claro es el de
1992 cuando bernard tapie se convirtió
en ministro de asuntos urbanos con
françois mitad y en mochilas y una
motivación increíble todo el mundo en
este equipo tiene el deseo de triunfar y
ganar su miedo durante su primer mandato
de manuel macro me sorprendió a francia
con los nombramientos de nicolás culo
como ministro de ecología y una antigua
personalidad de la televisión que
rechazó ser ministro del gobierno para
los tres presidentes anteriores otro
miembro sorpresa en el entorno de mccann
erickson mogetti un abogado penalista
estrella conocido por su impresionante
historial de defensa de clientes antes
de asumir el papel de ministro de
justicia ahora mascarón tiene la tarea
de tener en cuenta estos factores para
formar su gabinete por segunda y última
vez en el cargo y en otras noticias la
policía metropolitana de londres se
terminó con la pesquisa sobre el
escándalo por las fiestas durante el
confinamiento en la pandemia de
coronavirus en downing street en total
126 multas fueron impuestas 20 es en
esta última fase la finalización de las
pesquisas de scotland yard dan paso a la
publicación de una investigación interna
liderada por la funcionaria su grey y si
las conclusiones son negativas para el
primer ministro británico posición son
su partido podría someterlo una moción
de confianza
y al rey emérito de españa juan carlos
primero llega a españa este juez para su
primera visita desde que partió hacia
los emiratos árabes unidos- en 2020 el
monarca de 84 años regresa luego de que
las autoridades cerraran las
investigaciones en su contra por
presunta corrupción vamos con el informe
después de un exilio de casi dos años el
anterior rey de españa juan carlos está
de regreso en su país su itinerario
empieza en el noroeste de españa con un
invento de vela antes de concluir su
viaje al lunes con una visita a su hijo
el rey felipe en madrid el hombre de 84
años fue una figura venerada en el país
por su papel en la transición a la
democracia pero cayó en desgracia tras
una serie de escándalos incluyendo su
aventura con una empresaria danesa y un
viaje de caza a botsuana en los últimos
años de su reinado se descubrió su
riqueza oculta mientras surgieron
sospechas sobre tratos comerciales con
el monarca saudita quien asegura que
pagó 100 millones de dólares en una
cuenta bancaria suiza de una fundación
del rey juan carlos tras casi 40 años en
el poder abdicó en 2014 y viajó por abu
dhabi en 2020 después de que las
autoridades españolas y suizas lanzaron
investigaciones sobre presunto fraude
los fiscales abandonaron las
investigaciones pero el rey todavía
tiene que presentarse en la corte
suprema- en londres para un caso
presentado por su antigua amante danesa
que acusa el anterior rey de acoso tras
su relación
finalizamos en israel porque el ejército
de este país refutó que no vaya a
abrirse una investigación interna sobre
el asesinato de la periodista palestina
ya green a bucle ocurrido la semana
pasada cuando cubrían una redada en la
cisjordania ocupada a las autoridades
dejaron en claro que la decisión de
abrir o no una investigación interna de
la policía militar dependerá de la
abogacía militar una vez que haya
concluido la indagación operativa en
curso por otro lado la escena política
de israel se ve sacudida tras la
renuncia de rim agua suave y como
diputada del partido de izquierda méretz
un hecho que deja al gobierno de
coalición israelí en minoría en el
parlament o más detalles con nuestra
corresponsal se han ir a comer únicos
la renuncia de la diputada aida reina
wasabi deja al gobierno de nafta live
net como una coalición minoritaria en
concreto con 59 escaños frente a los 61
que reúne la oposición a corto plazo la
salida de la parlamentaria árabe del
partido de izquierda méretz supone para
el ejecutivo buscar más apoyos para sus
propuestas y negociar más algo que se
suma a la fragilidad de su coalición
surgida de una alianza de ocho partidos
que van de la izquierda a la extrema
derecha y que tiene una presencia árabe
inédita pero esto no implica un golpe
fatal para el gobierno israelí para que
eso pasara la oposición también dividida
debería votar en conjunto la disolución
de la que knesset con un nuevo llamado a
elecciones es decir que el bloque de
derecha y ultra religioso liderado por
el likud de benjamín netanyahu tendría
que unirse a la lista conjunta árabe y
el voto de reina hui suave y su voto por
ahora no apunta hacer caer el ejecutivo
en abril el parlamento israelí ya
presenció el abandono de la diputada
nacionalista y dit silman que había
dejado al gobierno y la posición en un
empate de 60 escaños mientras para
silman el gobierno no representaba
judíos y ccoo rina guys dijo no poder
apoyar más a una coalición que según sus
palabras fortalece su flanco de derecha
y acosa a los árabes de una forma tan
vergonzosa
múltiples desacuerdos se ejemplifican su
decisión pero la represión de las
fuerzas de israel en los funerales del
joven walid al sheriff y de la reportera
shirín a bucle además de redadas e
irrupciones en la mezquita de al-aqsa
han sido la gota final así la
incertidumbre vuelva a dominar la
política israelí que deberá resolver su
estancamiento para evitar unos quintos
comicios en apenas tres años
regresamos en breve con muchas más
noticias siguen en france 24
[Música]